So good morning.
Good morning.
All things small and consequential.
We're going to start with Paul because editing
the journal and you float among all these
fields.
So I wonder if it would be good for you to
give us a sort of a cosmic overview of this
technology and these sciences.
Really the field comes in from two directions
one is building from the bottom up like chemistry.
Where we attach atoms and molecules together
and then try and often make something functional
or something with new properties.
And then also sculpting from the, from the
top down much as we've done for centuries.
But in this case we use materials like silicon
where we'll cut it up in little pieces and
we'll turn some of the parts into insulators
and some into metals and some into functional
semiconductors that make a billion devices
on a chip that have enabled our computers
and phones and so forth.
Can you give just a quick description of the
difference between gold at the scale of someone's
watch and gold at the scale of an atom and
why it's so different?
Right so the properties change as one goes
from atoms all the way up to the to macroscopic
objects and in fact gold nanoparticles have
been used for centuries.
I think Vicki often shows in her talks the
Lycurgus Cup from Roman times were gold appears
red in stained glass and some of you will
know Rose glass.
So I have some mid 19th century glasses.
My wife got me as a birthday present and the
red color comes from gold nanoparticles that
were put in the glass.
So even, even long ago there were nanoparticles
they just weren't called that at the time.
Speaking of Vicki, so how did they get from
an application like, well in glass or whatever
you know modern application into the environment
around us?
Well actually that depends a lot on how it's
used so if something is you know in a piece
of glass you have to wait for the glass to
break down and in that case it's a problem
for many many generations from now.
But if you look at other applications, sunscreen
is a good one, they're actually held in an
emulsion that we rub on our skin and so they're
right there.
And in fact they're designed to coat the skin
so they're there in a large quantity.
So I think what's interesting is there's so
many different uses of nanomaterials, consumers,
businesses, in our devices and in device case,
or you know the glass you drink case it's
going to be in a landfill somewhere where
we're eventually going to see it or maybe
in an incinerator.
In the case of personal care products we could
be, you know, exposed to it every day.
So I think that's kind of the range of different
ways that nanoparticles can find themselves
interacting with us or interacting with other
species in the environment.
And what kind of work is required to sort
of clarify how they move and we'll get to
the risk question in a minute, but…
This is the exposure questions like, where
are they?
Well, so it's an interesting set of work so
they're really really tiny.
I'll add to this sort of how big are they
so I had this okay we're in Manhattan right
so if Manhattan was a human hair a, ten nanometre,
which is kind of bang on the middle of nano
materials would be about the size of a beach
ball.
To give you a sense of what we're dealing
so we can see a hair on her arm but we certainly
can't see these particles.
So part of the challenge is let's say one
of the places people have looked for titanium
dioxide which is in sunscreen nanoparticles
is actually in the filters of swimming pools.
So the concept is if it washes off people's
skin we can go there and look for it.
The other place they'll find themselves from
consumer use where they're not you know for
example bound in glass is at the end of a
wastewater treatment plant after we wash our
clothes for example.
And nanomaterials may come off they get washed
down the sink, they go to a treatment plant.
They're not going to be treated there.
They're not going to break down and they end
up in the sludge which is often used as agricultural
amendments so that particular area is one
that's of great interest the interactions
of the materials with plants and what happens
when they get into soils.
So these are not things that you're going
to smell.
The one thing I can say about most nanoparticles
is they don't they, my term as a chemist they
have no vapor pressure.
They're not going to loft into the air.
Really there are things in our food at least
the examples I'm giving we can talk about
aerosols but most of those applications we're
worried about eventually the sinks are going
to be sediments and soils at least from a
big environmental perspective.
We'll touch on some aspects of this again
in a few minutes but when I'm looking at that
dryer fluff, like what kinds of things would
it be unremarkable to see there?
Well that's a really interesting question.
Everybody knows their dryer fluff, right.
So if you could zoom in to this dryer fluff.
So a lot of clothes now are manufactured with
silver nanoparticles.
My grad students like to joke about it because
it's if you have clothes that have silver
nanoparticles embedded they will be anti-microbial
so you can in principle wear your underwear
for a month.
They seem to like it, graduate students.
My son will be very happy to hear that.
So if we value that as a society some of us
may then those particles are attached but
they're not they're not like embedded in glass
and they can fall off and when they fall off
they can end up in dryer lint and you can
pick it up and that particle may end up on
your hand it may end up part of your clothing
and there's a variety of ways in which you
could expose yourself to it or you throw it
in your garbage and it ends up in the waste
dump of your local community.
So the point is there's not a lot of mechanisms
for nanoparticles to be degraded and once
they're in water or soil they tend to stay
there unless there's some other process that
occurs.
Yeah, so now we'll move to the toxicity question
we know it's flowing in around it’s in the
dryer fluff.
But Som, Som is a preferred sort of shorthand
first name for you, Som?
S-O-M, not something else.
Oh yeah okay.
I see you said your students sometimes call
you something else, but we won’t talk about
that.
So toxicity, how do you go about, how did
you become interested in this question?
Well the whole nano, I got interested when
I was a child actually.
You have something called a plant, touch-me-not
plant.
And you touch it.
The leaves will fold and the stem will drop.
That's because there’s a nano structure.
There are nano cells here and the water squeezed
from it and it is brought down.
And that's where I got interested first.
And of course I didn't know why.
And also some of the some of the animals like
chameleon can change its color because of
the different nano cells on the top and the
middle and the pigments get mixed.
And so in nature there is always nano at play
and it has not been harmful.
And only maybe the engineered nanoparticles
are harmful.
Or they’re harmful, we’re immune to it.
We got used to it, you know.
The nano is not new, nano has been there for
centuries.
Like you've mentioned, even before that, nano
has been there.
So the question is engineered nanoparticles,
how do you mitigate that toxicity?
You asked what is the opportunity.
I think that's where the opportunity is, making
and following, there's a lot of work done
already, how to mitigate the nano toxicity,
and then how to use it even for, using drugs
in brain, to cross blood brain barrier.
That's where the opportunity is, you have
all those nanostructures in brain and how
can you influence it?
But I also I'm interested not only in nano
in size, most of the opportunity in my mind
is nano in time.
You go to the millisecond, femtosecond, things
happen.
When an atom comes towards each other in in
less than a femtosecond they react, and we
know very little about it.
One Nobel laureate who got Nobel prize following
that, he died recently.
I think that's where the greatest opportunity
is because things happen so fast that that's
nano in science, nano in space, not in nano
space, nano in time.
Temporal.
By the way is that part of the difference
between a substance at a larger scale and
a substance at the atomic or molecular scale
that the reactions can be faster the way it
reacts with other materials or whatever?
Well there’s more surface area.
And so you can take advantage of access to
the, to the atoms you're trying to use that
way.
That's why in catalysis we try and disperse
the material we're using and often those are
expensive and so a more efficient way to use
them is to make them little, so more the atoms
are exposed.
So the smaller…dicing something up gives
you more surface area for the same volume
and more reactivity?
At some point it's all surface but also the
properties change as you get smaller and you
can use that to advantage as well.
So I guess the atom is the smallest most surface
But you have to hold it usually in some way.
So we usually support it on something else.
So where would you look for toxicity questions,
you know I think we all start to think about
ourselves you know as a consumer first, but
what about occupational exposure?
I assume is anyone studying the sweater factories
in China?
For, I would assume the first place you would
want to look to see if there is a human impact
is not in in our households but in the manufacturing
center.
Have you looked at that at all?
Exactly the waste material, electronic waste
material that is sent to China and they break
up and without any kind of protection from
the mouth they break and the toxic materials
cartridges and everything is breathed all
the time.
That's where some regulations are not there.
Regulations are not here either in the manufacturing
and transport of material, not as much regulations
there.
But there, a lot of people are getting affected
and nobody's following it but they have to
make a living and then the residual material
is dumped in the nearby river.
So that's China and India.
I would say the first place you look is in
the laboratory not in the manufacturing process,
right?
We have experiments we can do that will associate
classes of materials with risk or safety and
so we can design the materials that we use
in manufacturing and those processes to keep
the people working there and all of us, later,
safe.
Wait, are you talking, in the laboratory you
mean…
Doing the experiments.
…in terms of knowing that there is a pathway
that could produce a pathology?
That's right.
So choosing the materials with safety in mind
and choosing the manufacturing processes with
safety in mind.
So there are, that's a that's a big effort
Vicki led one of those before she moved to
Brown when she was back at Rice University.
Andre now at our university and a number of
other places around the world study exactly
that.
Are there classes of materials that we can
proceed safely to commercialization and are
there others where we need to understand more
about either the safety issues or define the
materials themselves better to understand
which would be safe to use and which not.
And really we can guide technology development
by the results of you know what we learn.
The, the, the exciting part of nano is it’s
at the scale of function of biology.
Som mentioned that already, I’m married
to a neuroscientist who likes to say, well
the brain's always been nano where have you
people been for millions of years?
And, you know, when you study the biological
interactions, some are bad and some are good.
And so there are tremendous potentials for
therapy, therapies developed with those biological
interactions and part of the fun really is
going in and seeing OK well not only are these
materials safe, but they're protective in
some ways.
So Vicki, can you talk a little bit about
the work that was just described there you
know?
So I think the concept of ‘safety by design’,
so if we go back, you know I think I got into
this concept because I was reading in the
ACS, American Chemical Society, our publication
CNE News had just done a study of like, in
the 1990s why people don't become chemists.
And it turns out it's the least popular science
especially for parents, they don't want their
kids to become chemists.
And one of the reasons is the association
with pollution and I'm like well “that's
terrible.”
Why is that?
And and you sort of go back in history and
you can see chemists solved you know really
tough problems by developing new kinds of
chemistry.
But then there are always these environmental
gotchas right?
You know ten or twenty years later and so
it had been associated with that.
So the concept I think that is a lot of chemists,
green chemistry, safety by design, is maybe
chemists, if we start asking ourselves really
early when we build anything novel whether
it's a nanomaterial or a molecule.
Hey I know this is going to do something really
good.
Like for example be a great insecticide and
wipe out malaria, but on the other hand how
might I also think about ways it could be
bad?
And then could I get the good part of it,
the functionality I want by also minimizing
what I know could be dangerous.
That means we need to know the science well
enough to know what makes something dangerous.
So among all of our nanomaterials you know
which ones are going to be sociopaths, so
to speak, and how do we train them not to
be?
If you want to use that analogy.
And I think that concept that a chemist as
a maker, because that's what chemists do,
has a responsibility to think about what might
be the consequences of a novel material or
molecule and also what might be the benefits,
so we do both together.
And it's an interesting sort of balancing
act because the two disciplines of toxicology
and the applications areas are quite distinct
although fundamentally very related.
But I think that's the concept, so I can give
an example it's actually in our sunscreens.
So the material, this gets back to the surface
titanium dioxide absorbs ultraviolet light
which is what protects our skin from radiation
of the sun.
So that material is nano scale.
And the reason that's a good thing in your
sunscreen is it's not white.
Who is old enough here, I can't see the audience
but remember where we used to put the white
on our nose.
That's because titanium dioxide particles
were huge they were like big boulders and
they scattered light and they kind of felt
chalky, right?
So consumers love it when you have clear nice
smooth sunscreen and that's the nano scale.
But it's still observing UV.
The problem is it's now small enough that
it can interact with your body in ways that
big boulder couldn't.
And in particular the other thing about nano
scale TO2s is highly reactive and under UV
light can form a, nasty free radicals which
was the point of putting it there in the first
place.
So in any case the safety by design solution
is to coat it it's like a peanut M&M, you
get the titanium dioxide in the middle but
you don't want that reactive surface.
So you put on the surface an aluminum oxide
coating which doesn't affect the UV absorption,
but it precludes the chemistry from happening
at the surface.
So that's I think and in fact many but not
all of the manufacturers of our sunscreens
have to have gone to that route to sort of
get the benefit but then going that extra
step and some extra cost to make it a bi-layer
material or two component.
Paul I want to go back to you a bit on, just
to make sure we have a clear picture of the
landscape.
Which, in the magazine and the journal that
you edit, when you look across which sectors
of business are most in this arena.
How much funding is coming in how much of
it is oil, renewables, clothing.
Can you give us just remind us again of the
landscape of this?
Sure.
So we had a whole panel last night on energy
ranging from capture and harvesting and conversion
to storage transmission and so forth, those
are enormous areas.
Electronics has really been a driver
Drugs.
Drugs to a smaller, there's a lot of research.
There are only a few drugs that are in in
the clinic now, there are more in trials.
It would seem to be an arena where there will
be a lot of potential because a much smaller
amount of something you know…
Not just much smaller amount but you can you
you can put combination drugs and timed release
together.
Part of the problem is how do you get those
approved?
So there's just working backwards trying to
make the simplest nano delivery system he
could possibly make.
Mark Davis at CalTech put together nano delivery
material that only required 61 volumes reporting
to get approval to go to trials.
Oh my god.
And when people make you know much fancier
combinations, given the way things are now
it's almost unimaginable that one could take
those all the way to the clinic so…
That reminds me of something I read in preparing
for this which was that just looking at gold
that there is like, someone did an analysis
that showed that the responsiveness or issues
around gold or what was it called…at a certain
level like a mid-level there's more impact.
And then less and then…
Yeah it’s like Goldilocks, you know too
small is good, too big you know, it's like…
Which would make a drug issue…
Things that make it a good drug can also get
people queasy about potential risks and I
think I think the FDA examples are good ones
because there you have a regulatory process
that's very…well I won't say adept but is
set up to handle novelty because it's constantly
evaluating new things and is constantly weighing
risks versus benefits in a particular way
and it has yeah it's been incredibly hard
especially for the more exciting nano materials
to get through those hoops and unless the
disease it's curing is you know has no other
people have no other hope.
So there are certain cancers in which there's
been more progress that sort of chronic disease
but I think that it's an interesting case
study because when we looked at examples from
our center at Rice of things that were moving
into human trials it was on the order of about
12 years from when those first papers saying
hey this could be a possibility to when it
even got into human trials which is much slower
than you know probably about a factor two
slower than other materials.
Yeah regulation is really set up to work on
chemicals which can be precisely defined in
general.
And when we make new nanomaterials there are
usually mixtures and often when we manufacture
them it's going to be easier to make a mixture
than to make an absolutely atomically precise
structure.
And so if you had to treat every new nanomaterial
like a chemical, we don't have enough money
and we don't have enough animals in the world
to do the required testing and so we have
to become smarter about that.
And that's one of the places where that hierarchy
of trying to define groups of materials that
appear safe and can be tested together, hopefully
can be commercialized safely.
And we can do those more defined experiments
both on the material side and the testing
side.
As you know as needed to to develop other
materials and apply them.
Can you talk a little bit about the work you've
done on nanoparticles and how they behave
in plants and soils and stuff like that.
Yeah I mean soils are fascinating.
I may go off a little bit of tangent here.
So plants are remarkable living systems because
now I am not a plant biologist I was fortunate
to work with some really good ones like a
lot of nano scientists and what they do is
they are really good at mobilizing what they
need from the soil and they do that in partnership
with microbes that grow at their roots.
And so when a nanoparticle ends up there remember
I said the reason we're studying plants is
we're pretty sure that's going to be a sink
for a lot of nanomaterials coming out of wastewater
treatment.
So consumer applications and others, that's
where they'll be.
And so what plants can do is you sort of have
this image that there is an organism and there's
a nanoparticle and they're going to interact
and the nanoparticle is going to kind of stay
the nanoparticle.
But actually the chemistry that happens in
the roots not even in the plant but at the
root system can be very aggressive and it
can actually dissolve and break down nanomaterials
quite quickly in a way that we don't see in
other organisms.
And so one of the features of a lot of the
emerging nano plant studies is that if you've
got nano materials in soils and they're really
close to root systems, they’re going to
dissolve.
They're going to become soluble and the plant
is going to try to extract elements from that
and that can be a good and bad thing depending
on the plant system.
The other thing we learned is that most plants
don't take up whole nanoparticles.
Plants are very tight.
They don't, they've developed a lot of defenses
against plant viruses which by the way one
of my favorite plant virus is cowpea mosaic
virus is a 15 nanometer sphere.
So the only way it can get into a plant is
with an insect punching a leaf.
So plants have actually, they’re quite difficult
to get into and their modulation that the
plants activity at the root system seems to
be the dominant issue and also plants draw
enormous amounts of water from soil.
So my colleague was doing work with cottonwoods
and they would just draw all the nanoparticles
as huge pressure so you could have them everywhere
in the soil but they get pulled just because
of the water flow into the plant root system.
So the exposures accumulate at the roots where
they undergo—now the one really not such
a good thing that I think can happen is some
nanomaterials or anti-microbial, and the microbial
communities in plant root systems are crucial
for doing what they do.
And so when that gets knocked out the plants
get extremely unhealthy.
And that's really the primary way that you
can affect agricultural productivity but you
can also see with some other materials you
can get you know actually plants grow better.
We had one experiment we did where we saw
an enhancement of our plant growth and that
was partly because of the minerals that were
getting released by the nanoparticles.
Is there a prospect…
One important use of nanoparticles in agriculture.
One of the main problems in agriculture is
nitrogen utilization efficiency.
Lot of fertilizer is wasted and that nitrogen
utilization efficiency can be improved by
using nanoparticles.
By that I mean you dilute nanoparticles to
the root to deliver the nutrients and nitrogen
there.
So that on the top it's not wasted.
And I think you've mentioned the enzymes that
the that the roots generate can extract things
from the nanoparticles, if the nanoparticles
are properly designed.
There's a lot of opportunities there.
Well this is good.
I wanted to shift back into the prospects.
We've talked a lot right now already about
some of the questions about impacts but.
You know risks and benefits tradeoffs is always
there so…is there anything else in agriculture
that sounds like a pretty interesting idea
because precision delivery of anything is
what you want.
Another thing is to imitate we have a bio
solar project.
To imitate the plants, what the plants are
doing.
The leaves collect the photons and collect
electrons.
That all depends again on the nanostructure
of the leaves and how do they how do you increase
the efficiency of conventional photons electrons
is the problem that the efficiency is very
low.
People think that in general by controlling
the morphology of the enzymes the way they
dance with each other I think the efficiency
can be increased.
By the way I don't use in the ADF analogy
to the the I have a project called carbon
dioxide to champagne, dioxide is now no problem
but carbon tax of champagne.
Carbon dioxide can go into carbonate to formate
various alcohols.
They all have pathways with activation barrier.
If you can selectively decrease the activation
barrier for carbon dioxide to ethanol we are
like ethanol right or formate is better ethanol.
Selectively decrease that activation barrier
that to be very good.
And we can do that using copper nanoparticles
that are doped.
Why copper we don't know.
But doped that again shows the heterogeneity.
Their doped means only a few atoms of water
you dope with in the copper does increase
the activation barrier as carbon dioxide goes
to formate and then alcohol.
So that's a good example of the beneficial
use of the heterogeneity but I have to know
that.
So I wanted to talk to you more about medicine
we talked about medicines pharmaceuticals
but where else in medicine can this play a
role?
In health and health care generally?
Yeah so I mean just in sunscreen is a simple
example we can build in capabilities to nanoparticles
that we apply there.
There are tremendous opportunities in diagnostics
so we can we don't have sensors that we put
on as—they’re called temporary tattoos,
but they’re really stickers.
There's one that’s just being distributed
now to look at your UV exposure I think L’Oreal’s
giving it out in a dozen or so countries to
say…
So it's a cumulative exposure thing?
Right and so, these you know a lot of people
have Fitbits, I think Vicki has one on or
some equivalent right that measure exercise.
There's a lot more that we could measure.
You can tell when someone's dehydrated.
For athletes there’re sweat sensors they
can see that you know the composition lines
coming out of you are changing over time and
that can be an alert.
You know you need to you need to stop at the
next table in the marathon to pick up more
water electrolytes there.
The great opportunity I think is in medicine
is delivering where the cancer cells are.
I use the example of when you take aspirin
you have no side effect but if you have chemotherapy
lose hair and everything.
But if you can use that that chemical it can
kill the cell only where the tumor cell is,
then chemotherapy will be just like aspirin
and it is possible now, people like at MIT
has shown that using nanoparticles, it can
go there and attack where the tumor cell is
and no other cell.
And that will be the really the holy grail
I think.
Attack where the damage is.
I would think a little bigger.
I mean first of all I'm not sure we can make
a heat seeking missile yet to a cancer…
…but they can, they can…missile drugs.
Lot of people do that…
Yeah but their efficiency is pretty low.
Meaning if you take a dose, it’s better…
I know people who are alive because of his
technology…
No I'm not saying it's not.
I'm just saying we should be cautious in saying
that 100 percent of the drug goes to the cancer
cell because it's rare that that happens.
But it is true side effects can be reduced
by delivering properly…
But I think really you know kind of one of
the other themes at this festival that I think
is really an interesting question is if you're
going to make materials artificial materials
that integrate with our bodies and that's
really what we're starting to do with these
devices like actually become part of it, what
is that interface going to look like and what
we've been doing to date is taking large boulders
you know macroscopic materials and shoving
them into people's bodies.
And of course the body is not happy with that
it's got a lot of reactions to having a macroscopic
element put inside of it.
So you know my hypothesis is that actually
nano structured materials are the ideal thing
to help us make kind of this seamless integration
between the artificial world and the living
systems now doing that has a lot of consequences
and presents a lot of challenges.
But I believe that that's what you know if
you were to go 50 years in the future you're
going to find the tattoos or you know implants
in the brain or you know our clothing, the
ways in which it will interact with this will
be largely defined by materials and with nanoscale
structures and dimensions.
What's for this forward on that front already,
is there some particular niche?
Well there’s…I’m looking at Paul seeing
if he wants to pick one of the sci fi examples
or if I should.
Well you know there is plenty of accessible
space on us so for instance there are two
or three hundred species that live in your
mouth.
Some are protective.
Some turn on you and give you cavities or
root cavities or if you are going to get a
periodontal implant they're going to eat around
the implant it's going to fall out.
And dentists and periodontists know that but
they don't yet have any reconnaissance for
those species.
It isn't that difficult to imagine when you're
getting ready for an implant to get a swipe
and check if you have that bug for the month
preceding.
And so those kinds of things will come.
I think much sooner than the ten or twenty
years I'm hoping you know in the next few
months we develop the technology and then
it gets out there very quickly.
I'll give you the other example and you'll
have to tell me how sci-fi this is.
But for example we were just talking about
this before we came on the number of people
now and the opportunities in neuroscience
and neurology for the implantation directly
of electrodes into people's brains for treating
disease.
And the problem with that is many many many
problems.
But if you could make those electrodes highly
conductive and also flexible that's something
that biological systems are very mechanically
sensitive.
Almost all examples I've seen would tell us
that and so if you can integrate those electrodes
and make them less foreign to our brains then
what you're going to find is they last longer
they have less side effects and that's something
that you can do by manipulating material structure
on the nanoscale.
I mean that's a far reach, so I'll look at
Paul…
Vicki’s very kind because it's something
my wife and I work on together.
That reminds me I’ll just ask this out of
the blue…when I did my master's thesis in
journalism at Columbia I was on organ transplantation,
the future of organ transplantation.
I did a piece about a profile later for Discover
Magazine of a organ transplant recovery coordinator
and lately I've been tracking literature.
Because as we move to autonomous vehicles
and stuff, the number of donors is going to
become a…it's already a problem it's going
to be a huge problem so is there any role
here for antirejection with organs?
Yeah several yeah there's several things in
transplants or hospitals sort of built on
the back of some fantastic transplant surgeons
and you know we have a problem right now in
terms of harvesting organs that you know someone's
in a motorcycle accident and they get caught
up and you know ship to a bunch of different
patients and Singapore last year six people
died from one donor from infected organs and
that's something that happens regularly, there’s
not time for reconnaissance you know from
the point of collection of the donor to implantation.
And you know as you know if you follow transplantation
all kinds of things happened with immunosuppression
we basically give an artificial cancer to
many of the recipients that leaves them in
the hospital for months afterwards under protection.
Because of their first compromised immune
system and then the diseases that we induce.
And so there are all kinds of opportunities
there and connections being made really between
the transplant surgeons and the people in
nanomedicine to try and overcome some of those
some of these issues.
Interesting one thing we were talking about
earlier backstage was how your specializations
can have potential value in a host of different
disciplines and you tend to float I think
when you’re talking about floating it seems
that collaborative approaches to the science
and innovation seem to be vital.
I thought maybe I’d be curious for each
of you to describe whether you've had an experience
where that's become manifest.
Vicki.
I yeah I mean I think if you're a nano scientist
you actually are a collaborator.
The field was sort of started in that way
in many ways.
So what my interesting observation about collaboration
is is I sort of say two things to my students
because virtually everything I do is collaborative
you know first of all different disciplines
present different challenges for collaboration.
So I've learned through being a nano scientist
that dealing with toxicologists they have
a culture and they have a thing that they…so
there's a value system that comes with your
your core discipline versus dealing with physicists
they’re going to have completely different
sets of issues.
So part of working well and understanding
these disciplines is to know what are they
going to really care about and how do you…so
it isn't just communication and terminology
but it's understanding what am I going to
value my core training is as a chemist versus
what they're going to value and there's something
about I think it's shaped when people are
undergraduates this sort of disciplinary identity
and reinforced in graduate school so part
of the part of the gulf is to share of what's
going to be important when you do science.
How many replicate experiments are you going
to have to do.
And of course there's the language figuring
out you know my favorite example in nano is
if you're a chemist you learn how two atoms
interact through something called bond theory
and if you're a physicist you learn solid
state structure and they seem very different
but they're actually the same, right.
And so the field I think revealed that as
those two areas came together.
But it is really I think a matter of really
appreciating that even though science is objective
disciplines have value systems and part of
effective collaboration is kind of understand
oh I'm working with a surgeon they're going
to be really focused on a quick tool and they're
going be very focused on patients as opposed
to dealing with a physicist…
And they’re going to be very egotistical…
Yeah they’re going to be very busy and they’re
going to be very arrogant and willing to try
anything.
In my limited experience.
And I think as scientists we sometimes don't
want to talk about you know culture within
science or the personality elements and I
don't know if I'm going that far but I think
in collaboration it's really revealed to me
how important that is and when you get that
right and you understand them and they understand
you is when you usually are able to have a
really great working relationship and make
you know make the progress you need.
Now we're going to move into the sort of the
interface with society more generally.
A couple of things that come to mind.
One is to ask you which lessons from history
worry you the most when you think about where
nano is going to go now, whether it's looking
at what happened with DDT or more recently
with GMOs where you have this Monsanto effect
where most people who many people who have
a concern about GMOs it's really their concern
about industry or about something about a
particular company and and a lot of the interest
in this arena are corporate as well.
So I don't know if you each have a sense of
kind of like your worry about how this is
going to play out going forward.
I think the whole reason we're here is we're
trying to take a thoughtful approach.
The field has established some of the leading
investigators who work at that interface of
materials and safety as well as new materials
and medicine.
When you do essentially the same measurement
looking for positive and negative effects
and so really what you're doing is sorting
and when you combine those those areas you
learn more the biology and you know you're
able to do an end run you know maybe around
the complete characterization in some cases
and then identify you know where one needs
to know more.
And I think the next step for the field and
commercialization is making some choices as
to which technologies to push based on the
results.
And I think we’re right at that crossroads
now where we have so many different possibilities
in so many different areas of application
that if we put that in as part of the feedback
loop then that's where we avoid the missteps
of other fields in the past.
that we've got what is important may be, asbestos
was very good for insulation and everything
it was good for the society.
And then there was asbestosis just wanted
to make sure that it's no nanosys around the
corner.
And if you ignore it and if we don't have
the technology to mitigate it then there'll
be nanosys and there will be I suppose if
you spend more money now to remove asbestos
and nanoparticles would be even harder to
catch.
So that is what we have learned from asbestosis
and whatever that term is called, silicosis.
They are all good, all these good materials.
They have benefits like you said you have
to also know the side effects and even medicines
have side effects.
You know so we have to swallow that but try
to control the side effects.
So this gets this gets back to the safety
by design paradigm.
Can you do better.
Do we always have to learn by going uh oh
we didn't think of that?
Yeah I mean I think so.
I think my worry is sort of twofold.
First of all you know even though we're talking
about nano and its risks it's actually kind
of a laboratory experiment for the first time
a discipline is really trying to get ahead
of the curve since we know the technology
has unintended consequences.
I mean I can't think of one maybe somebody
will come up with one that is all good and
everybody loved it.
Forever and ever.
But my sense is that we're kind of trying
to figure out how it works…
Chocolate, actually…
Chocolate?
I'm sure.
No I get migraines from chocolate, so I’ll
fight you on that..
So my sense is that you know society has to
grapple and by society I mean the public of
which I am one.
With…we want the benefits like we want our
Fitbits.
And if you sold me a Fitbit that worked better
because it actually was part of my body I
would probably buy it.
But you know so the consumer demand for better
sunscreens that are not white and chalky is
sort of what's driving this process.
And I think that's partly an area that I wonder
how consumers are going to be part of this
and saying hey I want a label or I want this
to slow down here's where I'm willing to accept
a risk here's where I'm not willing to accept
the risk.
And I think that there's a there's a challenge
there that I worry about which comes actually
with labeling because I don't think consumers
know necessarily and I think that's keeping
them out of some of these some of the ways
in which they may influence this large sort
of corporate academic sort of you know train
that’s left the station so to speak.
On the science front
You know I'm going to and this is a broken
record.
I'm going to worry about the field moving
too fast towards trying to do testing rather
than trying to establish the general principles
by which we can do safety by design.
So if you've got a product that's got a sunscreen
you want to know how do I know if it's toxic
and that does us no good in helping us design
it more safely.
We actually have to do a little bit more fundamental
science and it is extraordinarily hard in
this particular climate.
I didn't mean to say climate.
I was going to try to avoid that word.
To try to make that case for slower more methodical
work that is linked to that potential.
And I think you know going too fast you won't
be able to develop these really fundamental
mechanistic understandings that you really
need to do effective safety by design.
So I think that's my scientific worry.
But Som this gets back to something you kind
of mentioned in passing talking about sunscreens
that there are natural solutions that might
be more beneficial but often if you're a company,
big cosmetic manufacturer or something your
interest is efficiency and production and
profitability.
And and you know consumer confidence but it
might lead you in a direction that wouldn't
necessarily be in the end the the best choice
for what you were talking about.
I mean when all the money flowing into the
field how much of it is related to the sustainability
questions or as opposed to the, boy can we
manufacture sweaters more efficiently now
or whatever?
A while ago, at least four years ago the consumers
were wanting more green products but then
the economy became bad, they got away from
that.
But there was a survey done we showed that
the consumers want green products.
There was a U.S. news site I remember the
cover say go green or go out of business.
There was a pitch and that was consumer group.
That's because there is an association in
UK, which showed that every sample of breast
milk analyzed showed cancer compound, every
not not ninety-nine point nine, every sample
of the breast milk analyzed some carcinogenic
compound.
So when that came out along with some other
company, which marks red blue green, then
consumers are driven that way.
Until the economy suffered.
Let's go back to cosmetics for a second because
for me those are great thermometer of public
perception.
So I’ll tell you a secret, I like going
to cosmetic scanners and when you go to them
in the U.S., nanos used for promotion of cosmetics
and if you go to cosmetics counters in most
Asian countries you charge more for things
that are nano.
And if you go in Europe you don't mention
nano.
And that's something that we as a community
are trying to address so exactly the association
you made that people don't think of nano as
GMO but have an understanding of what it is
we're doing that isn't supplied by a science
fiction writer and it is really a race right
now for that public perception.
A place, let me talk about another field for
a second so plastic microspheres are being
taken out of cosmetics because of the environmental
consequences and the replacement for them
may well be some natural nano products.
There's some that are being tested now by
a number of different companies that will
be biodegradable and safe ways to deliver
the cosmetics that don't have any of the consequences
that the plastics do.
So I think you'll see those you'll see those.
You know as soon as one can scale up the production.
Opportunity in biodegradability is great but
it is controlled biodegradability that you
don't know.
You don't want to make it and biodegrade tomorrow,
is going to be on the shelf for six months
one year.
So you want it to biodegrade in maybe in one
year or something we need to get to the water
and so on.
So it is controlled biodegradability is the
key opportunity I think.
This brings up something else which is you
mentioned Europe the difference in Europe
and perception and here and in Asia in dealing
with all these issues GMOs, nuclear power.
This I assume Crispr genetic technology coming
forward.
I think we would like to think there's one
sense of what the precautionary principle
is but I've yet to find it that everyone in
this room might have a somewhat more common
sense of precaution when they look at technology
and innovation because they're sort of a select
audience.
But you look at the global landscape and it's
all over the place so there will be opposition.
There will be people who will and organizations
that will come at you in a hard way.
I've seen in the literature already that you
see headlines, one piece that was in our background
briefing from Business Insider from last year
talks about…This is the Patagonia fleece
finding how much of this fleece is out in
nature and this is a shocking amount of these
fibers more than 64,000 pounds into oceans
and streams every day.
But 64,000 pounds over a lot of oceans.
And then you get to this question of actual
measurement of impact is different than measuring
the presence of something.
So but it's gonna be it's gonna be a fight.
There will be…
But it's less likely to have opposition from
the east.
I think the Eastern culture case for the human
beings and plants and bees and so on and so
forth.
I think they, I’m not saying Western isn’t,
but Eastern seems to care for years they have
been studying conscience and soul and things
like that.
I think there will be less opposition from
that part of the world wanting to care for
the planet, you know leave the planet better
than I found it.
So there may be opposition from some countries,
but as a whole, less.
But as a manufacturer must be hard because
Europe even on standard chemicals they require
testing on chemicals that we lead right into
the market right now.
I think some of the most compelling social
science I've seen on why cultural differences
are there and this is kind of a catch all
word but sort of intuitively made sense to
me has to do with trust.
So how much the public trusts in their governments
ability to regulate in the sciences you know
in the sort of academic systems’ ability
to be independent.
And how open the society is are all factors
that kind of govern whether or not the public
will accept a risk because the reality is
there they are kind of trusting a variety
of different stakeholders to tell them what
it is and to inform them, right?
And I think that very in Europe they're really
not very trusting in these kinds of panels
in Europe that it's it's a very different
kind of feel.
And that's why we're doing this.
So if we can you know show not only show how
we're proceeding but also listen to what concerns
are then not only can we address those but
we can learn something about how to how to
proceed and you know what more to do.
It's it's really a conversation even though
you're all sort of blocked by bright lights
right now.
You will be part of the conversation, in a
minute we’re going to go to questions shortly.
But I would say the one thing that I can say
and it's funny when you're a scientist you
don’t like to have a policy statement because
my job is to create data not to make policy.
But there is one area that I do feel strongly
that is actually labeling on products and
I've had a lot of arguments with corporate
folks who say if we give people information
they'll just get afraid.
And we don't even know how to label things.
That second point is true.
The first point I don't know if I buy.
But I think that that sort of openness and
saying you know these are the ingredients
that are in this product and let you the public
have some important insight.
I think without that there there remains this,
I can't control the risk that I personally
am assuming, that I think is always going
to be in our way particularly with consumer
products.
So I've been pushing for a while on this one
with not a lot of success.
It’s the one soapbox I have.
Well this came up in a big way with GMOs and
still the problem was a lot of the labeling
initiatives that came up at the state level
were were implicitly punitive.
They were there to add and this is another
this is the question you just sort of made
the point you made about well what's on the
label.
Is it just X is here or is it implying this
is a danger.
I think that there this community because
what we have and the nature of our materials
I think we could probably if we had a really
good working...people work together.
I think we could deal with that issue in this
particular setting.
But I agree.
I mean is that a reason not to label or is
it a reason just to work really hard to make
sure the labeling you do is accurate and informative
to the people who need it.
Or would want it.
So from my perspective I don't think it fans
the flames but I'm certainly aware there are
others who think it does.
So I think that's a that's one really interesting
point.
And I see very different perspectives in both
the scientific and corporate community in
different parts of the world.
By the way another area where this came up
was fracking fluids up to the ground industry
was resisting saying what was in them and
that led to this whole suspicion factor.
Then Wyoming a state that's…Wyoming has
actually was one of the first states even
though it was Cheney's state.
It's an oil and coal state to move forward
with requirements for open listing and you
know it's all there for people to explore.
I'd like to start to think about the questions
and answers.
This one's for Vicki.
Do you use sunscreen, if so which kind and
why.
Consumers Report had a really good we actually
it was one of my favorite collaboration with
an NGO.
We worked with Consumers Report on analyzing
sunscreens.
But this is 2010.
So I never…I do I have kids, right, they're
teenagers now.
After doing that work I never use infant sunscreens
don't use anything that says infant.
And I tend to go for big brands that have
lots like would have a lot of money.
I can't name them because there are legal
issues but if you come talk to me after my
talk…the other thing that it caused me to
do because I actually didn't know this data.
But sunscreen washes off and in fact to get
the full effect of it you really have to reapply
it a lot.
So what it actually caused me to do, is when
I do go to the beach or go hiking in the desert
with my family I actually really into finding
the lightweight clothing and sort of covering
the body as much as I can.
And that actually keeps you a little bit cooler
too.
So my kids you know…
What a novel idea, like an umbrella?
Umbrellas go a little too far for my teenage
girl now.
But I think that they are both you know cover
up a lot and that's actually net safer because
the reality is if unless you are going to
be putting sunscreen on every 30 minutes you're
probably going to be losing the benefits anyhow.
I don't use sunscreen.
I don't I don't need it.
And there is an opportunity there.
Why don't I need it.
What is the mechanism that prevents the UV
absorption and melanin.
That's where the opportunity is.
Getting to the root of biological possibilities.
I got to ask you though what's the why not
the infant.
What was the infant issue?
So you remember I talked about safety by design
so we analyzed and you can read all about
consumer reports I'm not kidding.
So we analyzed pigments and we tried to determine
whether they were the peanut M&M types.
Did they coat their pigments and did they
use zinc oxide which is cheaper and has now
been found as we identified to be even worse
than the titanium, titanium dioxide.
That infant sunscreens by and large didn't
coat anything because of a variety of issues
related to new formulations and you never
want to put a new formulation into the infants.
You know they want to go with something they've
been using a longer time is how it's explained
to me.
So when we did the analysis of anything geared
towards babies we actually found the materials
they were making ten years ago I was surprised
by that finding but it was pretty consistent
across the board.
And when I asked they said oh well anything
infant we we use tried and true in this case
was actually not really great stuff in my
opinion you know.
And so in general though I think the other
thing I don't like to do.
We did some really…this is going to sound
strange, but you can get sunscreens from natural
sources and sort of the not so standard brands.
I would not recommend that we saw a lot more
variation.
So the kinds of pigments you need to purchase
are more expensive and they're harder to formulate.
So the suspension feels good and it lasts
for a long time.
The big companies know how to do that better.
Next question.
Could you mention the companies that are are
or are likely to benefit from nanotechnology?
Is that an investment oriented question?
Wow who won't?
Large companies such as Monsanto and the BASF
are already using it.
BASF in fact one of the ones that came up
with the brush that you can use to remove
dust, but then they had to back off when the
nanotoxicity question came up and the companies
which make skateboards and so on to make make
it make their skateboard so much better that
the less friction they benefit.
What I would say in the future probably the
small startup companies like the one I mentioned
probably has more opportunities to make new
products and so on.
So already BASF…Benz cars maybe I shouldn't
promote any company but Benz companies they
have scratch resistant.
And also it glows very nicely.
So those companies are already using nanotechnology
for better purpose, there are many others.
Drug companies of course many drug companies
are using for delivery of delivery of drugs.
In medicine it's the little companies that
are doing exploration and they're going to
get purchased by larger companies, so the
ones that have moved forward are into trials.
You can keep an eye on in terms of therapies.
There are tremendous moves forward in diagnostics,
energy storage companies, you know whoever
makes the more efficient faster charging larger
storage battery it's going to.
Going to be there for the people who want
electric cars and homes storage, it's an enormous
potential market.
I think that the question is which companies
won't, but.
One of the sectors that when I lived in Houston
for many years has really adopted, it's actually
gotten much more R and D oriented.
Is actually the oil and gas, the traditional
oil and gas companies.
And what really woke them up was actually
the development of natural gas and fracking
technology because it really shifted their
dynamic.
And it was fundamentally a technology break,
not a breakthrough but a sort of coordinated
thing that happened that made it possible.
And ever since about 2007, 2008 they've taken
a much more aggressive stance looking at incorporation
of new materials and you know everything from
I.T. to nano and to everything that they do.
So the efficiency particularly I think in
the natural gas areas both for storage and
extraction is something that those companies
are strongly focused on, because they now
see that it can really benefit their bottom
line which they didn't see that 10 years earlier.
They were kind of stuck in their ways and
just making money pumping stuff out of the
ground for such a long time.
It was fracking that woke them up because
really up until then it was like exploration.
Could you identify where there was the most
oil and if you were better at doing that than
your competitor you were more likely to make
the best bet.
Now it's kind of the Wild West in the very
different forms of carbon based energy that
are available.
I'm not saying it's a good or bad thing, but
it exists.
So if it's going to exist it's good to make
it more efficient and allow them to extract
cleaner fuels more efficiently.
So I think that, that that sector woke up
pretty recently and continues to invest heavily.
Primarily in efficiency of extraction.
They've always and you know maybe there'll
be a breakthrough in exploration based on
nanotech.
Oh yeah catalysis.
It has been there has been there for decades.
And you know one of the innovations I particularly
like is the idea of using nano porous materials
in part because the guy at Mobile who did
it has the same name as me, Paul Weiss, who
was my colleague back when I was at Penn State.
But that dramatically increase the efficiency
of oil refining in the energy content that
we could get out of what we took out of the
ground.
And so those advances preceded what much of
what we call the field of nanoscience and
nanotechnology.
After the oil spill in the Gulf of Mexico
they used some material which some said toxic,
the company which made it said it’s not
toxic.
Then there was an opportunity for companies
to make again proteins bio proteins, which
will coat the oil particles in such a way
that they will stay in nano form for a long
time.
And why is it good?
Because microbes have an opportunity to eat
that oil.
So this kind of nano films of oil droplets
had an opportunity, which some companies used.
That's where I got into the Stephen Hawking’s
episode of Brave New World.
Oh interesting, you mean so when the oil is
in smaller amounts it's easier for the microbes
to break it down?
There are many ways by which they burn up
the oil.
That's one way.
There are many ways.
One way is to use the microbes to eat the
oil.
Well for microbes to eat the oil there has
to be a lot of surface area of oil droplets.
For that you have to have the oil droplets
in nano form.
So what you do is this biosurfactants…will
coat the nanoparticles and the film is so
robust that it will stay as an emulsion droplet
for a long time and the microbes can eat it.
Another question.
There was a comment earlier about distinction
between basic fundamental research and how
you mentioned that some of the problems that
you thought your field faced actually required
that in the current climate with sort of potentially
not conducive to that…I was hoping you could
expand a little bit more about whether you
think that's specific to your field or in
broader science and why you think that is
and just sort of your general comments on
that front.
Yeah.
It's a it's a really hard one.
So I think that since I've been it's it's
a double edged sword.
I would I would take some responsibility as
a scientist for this situation.
So you know back in the 70s there was Sputnik
and a lot of these agencies that are funding
us now got started with this sort of I call
it the fear the fear of Russia beating us
and then it sort of shifted to a hope argument
by investing in science and technology we
can have a better world a better economy more
jobs.
And that was sort of the different ways in
which we decide to fund what we do and I think
in our quest to make what we do more impactful,
so to link what we do in the lab which is
a fairly abstract detailed kind of work and
to make it relevant we're driven to make applications,
right?
We want to show that I didn't just say that
hey I could use my nanoparticles as an antioxidant
and use them in medicine some day I am going
to show you that.
And what I think that tilted is it made it
extraordinarily difficult to put forward much
more difficult to find agencies and programs
willing to do the solely fundamental…I would
call it I hate to use the word sort of trooper
but that the fabric of science is really the
repetition that people checking, and that's
harder to do now, you have to always focus
on the application and then you have to deliver
on that application and that's what you promised
and guess what that means you spend less time
systematically unraveling underlying mechanisms.
And I think that like I said I always I hate
to blame other people, I think as a scientist
I'm sort of guilty of it because I wanted
to you know in my career make things relevant.
And I think that's shifted the field and I
think nano has been part of that.
I would also say the climate of course is
changing for that and certainly the current
administration my early reads from my network
are not positive for fundamental science.
You know anything that I'm going to write
a proposal on is got to be I'm going to either
partner with a corporation or I'm going to
start a company or I'm going to.
So I don't have time and I don't have that
ability unless I can couch it and kind of
do it in drips and drabs.
So for me I find that more difficult.
I don't know if I'm the only one.
So we're close to wrapping up I want to give
you the opportunity to come up with a closing
thought but my my question for you and my
prompt for you going forward is as I said
at the beginning we seemed to be in a race
between potency and self awareness, between
what we can do and what we choose to do.
And I don't know going forward do you feel
we're on the right track to get that answered
in a way that people 100 years from now will
say, oh they kind of worked it out.
So I think you know as you heard one of the
advantages of the community is we bring in
people from other fields we're naturally curious
we talk across those fields and I think that
bodes well for looking at the consequences
and trying to explore those in advance and
engaging with the broader community as well,
in what the issues are how to proceed what
to develop.
What information you know we want to make
sure everybody has.
And so, you know I feel really a positive
outlook for the development of the technology
and in a safe way just because of that stance
really of the people in the field and where
we came from and how we interact.
Great.
Som, any last thoughts?
In terms of products, for the community to
accept and so on.
The companies have to be more transparent.
I know they have their own obligations and
then the then the community will accept.
But in terms if they want to end up by reemphasizing
the opportunity where probably there are no
toxic effects are studying the nano time,
nano second, millisecond, femtosecond.
This is not at all, this is one Nobel Prize
obtained several years ago that's where all
the Nobel Prize, those kids that’s where
the Nobel Prize is.
Good.
Vicki?
Yeah I think you know we're probably doing
as well as we could on this one.
I mean we're asking ourselves to look in the
crystal ball and see the future.
And we do that all the time at the beginning
of our grant proposals.
We're doing this because someday…and I think
now we're training ourselves to think about
it the other way.
And I think it's like I said I think we're
doing about as well as we can.
The only thing I would hope is that there
would be a really good public private partnership
to work on the issue of labeling.
Labeling, communication.
Well this has been a rich and wonderful discussion.
There's lots more to be learned going forward.
Thank you very much.
Thank you all.